a sad one for America that the
president's reckless activities
necessitated us our having to introduce
articles of impeachment bad thank our
six chairs confer long period of time
have been legislating investigating and
litigated today that came to a
culmination from the floor of the House
Budget Committee under the leadership of
Jerry matter of New York Intelligence
Committee under the leadership of Adam
Schiff with California brought the
articles of impeachment to the floor to
a conclusion where they have passed I
thank them for this and then this
leadership I thank congressman
chairwoman maxine waters of California
Ritchie meat of it Financial Services
Committee Ritchie near with
Massachusetts the chair of the Ways and
Means Committee carolyn Maloney the
chair of the bubbler forum to the
release type committee and of course
Adam Schiff the chair of the
Intelligence Committee for their great
work over a period of time as this for
to say before yielding to the Chairman
that I could not be prouder or more
inspired but then by the moral courage
of the House Democrats we never asked
one of them how they were going to vote
we never whip this boat we saw the boat
while you saw the public
some of them made we saw the result when
everyone else did the statements on the
floor about patriotism and about being
very true to the vision of our founders
and so I this full of something that we
did to honor the vision of our founders
to establish a republic the sacrifice of
our men and women uniform to defend our
democracy and that Republic and the
aspirations of our children that they
were a labor in a democracy and that we
have tried to do everything we can to
make sure that that is their reality
wheels here from our Chairman and then
we'll take three questions I'm now
honored to yield a great appreciation in
the step did your stainless chair of the
Judiciary Committee German ever